y los compromisos anunciados por los
gobiernos principalmente de eeuu y china
son suficientes para lograr reducir el
calentamiento global qué balance deja
esta cumbre
yo creo que es una cumbre muy importante
cierra el regreso de eeuu al
multilateralismo para responder a la
crisis climática que es el mayor desafío
que tiene la humanidad y además con
anuncios que son de la mayor relevancia
en primer lugar eeuu se compromete a
disminuir sus emisiones en un 50 52 por
ciento del año 2030 asimismo se
compromete a poder llevar a 0 generación
de energía con base en carbón a partir
del año 2035 y la movilidad eléctrica en
el país yo creo que esos son anuncios
muy importantes sumado a toda la
estrategia de la generación de energías
renovables sumado a toda la estrategia
de poder mover a los eeuu a una economía
verde y además algo muy importante y es
el compromiso
de que esto nos lo pueden hacer solos y
estamos hablando del país que emite el
15 por ciento de dióxido de carbono
equivalente y eso lleva a que hay que
hacer un esfuerzo multilateral y me
parece que es los anuncios que se
hicieron fueron muy importantes creo o
se esperaba más de la república popular
china les esperaba más de rusia pero
creo que es un gran paso el que ya al
menos esté en un diálogo si esté en un
diálogo multilateral para responder al
mayor desafío que tiene la humanidad
louis como creer las promesas de líderes
como el presidente brasileño llegue a
personar por ejemplo quien ha sido un
firme escéptico del cambio climático
bueno yo creo que latinoamérica tiene
una muy buena oportunidad en este
diálogo que se acaba de iniciar y con el
regreso muy activo de eeuu
al escenario del acuerdo de parís sin
embargo esta oportunidad de
materializarse con un gran liderazgo
de la región creo que los planteamientos
que se hicieron fueron importantes pero
si hay mucha incoherencia entre los
planteados por el presidente bolsonaro
en el sentido de que se comprometió a
proteger la amazonía que es un activo
supremamente importante para describir
la estabilidad climática global pero lo
que vemos que sus acciones no
corresponden a lo que dijo en la cumbre
en primer lugar ha debilitado las
políticas y las regulaciones ambientales
ha desmantelado las instituciones que
tienen que ver con la protección de la
amazonía y asimismo la ha reducido los
presupuestos y las acciones que ha
tomado son acciones que llevan
precisamente a lo contrario
entonces pierde mucha credibilidad hubo
incoherencia de parte de algunos otros
líderes de américa latina y yo creo que
lo que se reflejó en la conferencia es
que en la cumbre climática es que
américa latina necesita realmente
entablar diálogos regionales que
respondan más a las realidades de la
región creo que en el caso de los
líderes de américa latina tienen que
estar más en consonancia con la
evolución que ha tenido el debate
climático el debate climático tiene unos
componentes muy importantes de justicia
racial tiene y en este sentido hay que
involucrar más a las organizaciones de
comunidades indígenas de comunidades
afrodescendientes que están con activos
ambientales muy importantes